even well beneath the scorched fields of
somerset there are signs of the drought
work the way down inside
up in the chamber
we made our way deep into the mendip
hills through swilden's hole
and followed passages carved out by
water over millennia
but the driest summer in 50 years has
reduced the stream to a trickle
this is the mainstream that's flowed
from the surface through the passages
and here it's joined by a tributary
called rolling thunder now this water is
rained that has fallen on the soil come
through the rock
and as you can see it's been so dry
there really isn't much of it
beneath many parts of the country rain
is held in rock like a soaked sponge
overflowing as springs and also tapped
by water companies for drinking supplies
it's called groundwater and after eight
months of low rainfall
levels are falling
we've got kind of various factors that
will kind of affect the water that's
running down into the cave in general
yeah things are things are that a little
bit drier yeah things are a bit drier
than how maybe we'd see them over the
past kind of few years or so
in the southern half of england levels
of groundwater are below normal even
exceptionally low in some places
southern water is keeping a close eye on
the aquifer beneath the south downs it
pumps out more than 170 litres of
groundwater every second to supply towns
like brighton
we're monitoring it very very closely
you know we'll be be prepared to react
with you know hose pipe bands or you
know things like that if needs uh if
needs be i think the what's more concern
for us is the is the longer term it's
the you know it's the impacts of climate
change it's how we're managing water
supply you know for the next for the
coming decades if the sort of weather
that we've seen this summer is going to
become the become the norm
the soil is now so dry that even when
the autumn rains come it will take weeks
of wet weather before water starts to
refill the underground aquifers this
drought is likely to last even when the
summer heat fades
thomas more sky news in somerset